hey what's up YouTube alright we are
back this is my fourth day in a row
doing live streams has anyone in the
history of the internet live streamed
four days in a row they have okay I got
an answer really quick yes people have
done it many many times before probably
many more days before nonetheless here I
am we are the day we are one day
basically 24 hours out of the final
debate so will obviously talk a lot
about that I'm happy to talk about
Project Veritas we can talk about
WikiLeaks all kinds of stuff
there's obviously a lot going on we
still about twenty days for this
election and people are going completely
insane like it's just if you think that
we've hit bottom we are we're not even
close just think how nutty this thing is
gonna get before it's over I think both
these guys this guy in this gal Hillary
in Trump I think they have so much more
on each other and because it's such a
ratings machine right now it's just
gonna get worse and worse and I will say
this I don't think it's over yet I
really don't think it's over that I
think anything can happen so I'm happy
to share my thoughts on what happened
last night well do and ask me anything
you guys can ask me any question but it
can be personal private or about
politics or about Nintendo or basketball
or anything else and the reason that
we're going live all week in case you
don't know already is that we are
building a home studio it's our final
step towards true independence where we
will have no boss we will have no rental
stuff we will own and distribute and
control our content ourselves starting
next week just to prove to you guys how
hard we're working we're doubling our
content even though we're working
incredibly hard already
but we're doubling our content starting
next week we'll be tuned to interviews a
week once we have our live studio which
we have to we have to build out now and
that's what we're hoping you guys will
help help us out with once we do that
we're hoping to and do eventually you
know like a live weekly news segment
we'll live stream from the studio more
we'll be able to not only do more
interviews but we'll be able to do
longer interviews you know I was renting
before it the previous studio that I was
at which was great but sometimes we
realized he wasn't even financially
sensible to do more interviews because
it cost more to actually rent the studio
then we could profit from the video so
the more
I did the message less money we made
which obviously doesn't make any sense
so so it's the true last piece to us
being fully free and an Amir and David
work incredibly hard for me we've got a
great little production company here and
we've got so many people offer to work
for us and and work for free for us but
we want to pay people so we're putting
all the pieces together to have a really
awesome company here and hopefully talk
about issues that you think are
important classical liberal values and
and talk to people that are progressives
and that are that are conservatives and
everything in between and things that
are even more fringe than certain either
of those so that's what we're doing so
I'm giving live shoutouts to anybody
that donates on Rubin report comm /
donate where the PayPal link is and the
patreon link and patreon common report
and we've got a code we just opened up a
couple of hundred dollar slots if you
want to join us on the Google Hangouts
where we do these mini chats mini video
chats with people from all over the
world it's really cool and fun and you
get mugs and t-shirts and all kinds of
other stuff on there all right that's
enough housekeeping for now now I'll
take some questions and it looks like
the chat was quite lively before I even
got in here according to my team over
here so I'm here it's gonna fire off
some questions and yeah we do politics
whatever you guys want to do and I'm
alive breathing human being far more
human and animated than anything else on
cable TV tonight which is yes so prop 60
in California which a lot of people have
been talking about basically forcing
porn companies to have their performers
use condoms and healthcare and health
check-up so as far as the health
check-up part of it I'm basically okay
with that I think that would just be
them doing their due diligence and
responsibility as far as forcing them to
wear condoms I mean you guys know my
feelings are generally the government
forcing private companies and private
people to do things so if you if we can
trust
hopefully that these companies want to
keep their employees healthy and that
people have access to the right kind of
health care and information so that they
don't do risky things and things that
are gonna get them in trouble one way or
another I would
against forcing a company to do that
because truly the end of the day what
will happen if people want porn without
condoms well then if you say to the if
you say all right in California that's
the only way you can shoot it with
condoms well guess what all the
pornographer is it here are gonna go to
Vegas so they'll go to something right
outside and this is one of the issues if
you saw my interview with Randy Barnett
who's a constitutional law professor we
weren't talking about porn in condoms
specifically but one of the things that
he really laid out that I think was
really brilliant about why states rights
are important is he talked about the
foot vote now one of the reasons you
don't want the federal government to
control everything is that you
ultimately if the feds control
everything you have very little control
of your life because your only way to
say I don't like this system is actually
to leave the country but if you have
states rights and you allow the states
to say we're gonna tax differently we're
gonna have this different law in this
state you can have legal marijuana in
this day you can have you don't have to
use condoms and porn or whatever it is
what you do is you allow people to vote
with their feet foot vote so that you
can take your money your work your
economic benefits and you can take it to
another state that has that holds more
of your beliefs and if that state starts
doing well economically maybe then you
force some of those other states to
change that's how you I think create
real change using the individual using
the economy properly without slam it
without having the government slam down
edicts on everybody so yes you know I
always say the phrase the road to hell
is paved with good intentions the
intentions are good for people that want
this this proposition 60 to go through
they don't want people to get STDs
that's an admirable quality but the idea
that the government should force it down
everyone's throat snow plan attendant
when when people will just go to another
state is it's kind of silly and
short-sighted I think remember we're
giving a live shout out to the entire
time so I just want a quick thank a Kyle
who just jumped in on patreon and Jesse
who just jumped in PayPal thank you guys
America's geez what's my favorite kind
of cheese I did just have a cheddar
cheese cheese stick
but cheddar is not like hairy cheese I
love I love a good blue cheese I'll
I love I love a good Swiss cheese but I
think my favorite cheese of all time and
I've been really big on it lately
I do love feta I do love the feta cheese
you give me like a goat's milk or a
sheep's milk feta which is a little
softer than the people think of as the
regular feta I've got a good one from
maybe it's from Whole Foods in there
there's only a couple of things I can't
really go to food all the time because
it's what they call it old paycheck lose
everything some surgeons medicine they
do have a good sheep's milk feta
now I come up with some sort of 1% or so
Trump talked last night that he is
pro-life is what he said and that he
said he would appoint justices and and
this next president may get to appoint
four justices because of the age of some
of the justices right now so he said he
would appoint pro-life judges
now first up that statement in and of
itself is not really how it works you're
supposed to appoint judges based on how
they not on their political beliefs but
how they view the Constitution now I
know you'd be basically discern how
someone use it then you can figure out
what they think but anyway what he was
saying was I would have right to life
justices which ultimately would reverse
roe v wade which would kick it back to
the state so he was never so just to
clean up a little bit of what he said he
never said that he would have abortion
be federally illegal that's not what
reversing roe v wade reversing roe v
wade would kick it back to the states
roe v wade says it's a it's a woman's
right at a federal level in the entire
country now i would not be for a
reversing roe v wade i am pro-choice I
do not like abortion as I said in my
tweet last night I don't think most
really wanna have proportions and if
you're gonna take away to the right to
have an abortion what you're gonna do is
force a lot of women's having legal
abortions people are still gonna do it
and by the way all of these these
Republicans and people on the right who
are against abortion guess what if
they're children most likely were raped
or something happened they'd still find
a way to have an abortion so you're
going to create a situation where you're
gonna have poorer people doing it
illegal
that's that's not good at the same time
I do believe that at some point that
that entity that is in the woman at some
point is a human being maybe not an
inception when it's just the cosmic
snooze so to speak but at a few months
in what do you do what do you do if a
woman doesn't want to have that
pregnancy if you offer her no help then
she's gonna find a way to have an
abortion anyway so this is somewhere
where we have to I think for people that
are pro-life well if you don't want
someone to have an abortion then maybe
of the figure out ways to help them
either more easy ways to adopt or
something this is really where most
decent people can come together everyone
knows this is a very polarizing topic
and as I said last night people on the
right and make it sound like people on
the left ate babies people on the left
make Italian people on the right hate
women
neither one of those things are true so
let's kind of figure out how to have an
honest discussion about I personally
would not be for reversing roe v wade
but just to be very clear reversing roe
v wade does not make abortion illegal it
just puts it backs in the state hands
then you could be completely against
that George says what Decepticons are
Hillary Trump by the way we're gonna
we're giving probably primo comment
priority to people that are on patreon
so even if you just donate a dollar on
patreon you'll get you'll get primo
placement for David Namira to read any
questions
so what Decepticons are Hillary and
Trump well Trump let me think who who's
like really gaudy and over the top and
ridiculous well Trump I think would have
to be Starscream if you remember the
cartoons Starscream really always wanted
more and more power he's a bit of an
egomaniac
he was always sort of into like having
an insurrection against Megatron really
fighting the system so I would say Trump
is Starscream Hilary look Hillary's the
power structure she's running the show
so she's probably Megatron yeah I'd have
to go with that uh alright a couple
quick thank you you want to thank
homeless help on patreon thank you guys
and Chris who just jumped up on patreon
who increased his pledge so thank you
guys for giving shoutouts to anyone who
donates on either PayPal or
Dody oh and we've got an exclusive
patreon only stream after which is one
of the rewards that you can get on
patreon where it's just sometimes it's a
dozen people in there depending on what
time of day we do it sometimes it's a
couple hundred people out there but it's
very intimate and I get to chat with you
guys share a little personal stuff that
I can when it's out to fold to the full
masses all right no good asks on patreon
have I reached out smart inscri Kelly I
have reached out to him he follows me on
Twitter ID on him a few times
he hasn't got back to me but I feel like
I feel like it'll happen if you're
hearing squeaking I was getting a little
jealous that I'm talking to you guys in
squeak and Yoda over there
but I would be happy to have him on you
know he's obviously an extremely
controversial figure for those of you
who don't know he's the guy that got in
a lot of trouble when he increased the
price of I think it was cancer drugs
with HIV medicine okay so yeah and
subsequently has staked out a lot of
very unpopular positions money's created
some cancer drugs possibly all right so
so yes I've reached out to him and I'll
continue to reach out to him as a follow
me please aware of Who I am so hopefully
we can make that happen
what's my favorite Mel Brooks movie it's
gotta be Spaceballs Spaceballs is pretty
spectacular I watched it again about six
months ago and it's pretty great now of
course you guys know how I feel about
Star Wars so obviously that's that's the
easy one for me but there's there's so
much goodness in Spaceballs yeah I would
say space both Blazing Saddles is
phenomenal the best part scene ever in a
movie Young Frankenstein is great I
didn't love the producers movie I
thought it was actually pretty shitty
the play is good maybe you know you get
a couple did a couple bad ones story
towards the end of this sort of
moviemaking career but I still love the
guy I saw him once a New York City and I
said that um I think your topics aren't
entirely us-specific
will you ever have any experts from
other
my topics are entirely us-specific I
mean I've had tea no Sun and Nagi we did
a whole episode on Sweden I had two
Australians on in the last two three
weeks I had Rita Panahi who's a writer
for the Australian Sun and I had NBA
star Andrew Bogut I've had the leader of
the Assyrian army on I've had Douglas
Mari where we talk mostly about the UK I
had Bayan Sami Abdul Rahman who's the US
representative of the Kurdish regional
government certainly I can do more
surely I can do more and that's one of
the things that I would love to do I
want to do more i I had Tariq Vuitton we
talked about Indian Pakistan almost the
entire time and also Balochistan which
nobody talks about so I would love to do
more of that kind of stuff and that's
one of the things we'll do as we expand
the show this really these these few
months since we've done independent it's
just the beginning now is where we're
really gonna kick it up to high gear
well I mean I will literally have a
studio in my house and be able to just
take more and more content by the way
the more content that we take the more
revenue that we can generate and the
more revenue Denari the more people we
can hire and the more people we can are
the board so it's a nice little engine
that you guys are helping us out with
Rubin report all right let's go on and
by the way we think right now so it
looks like there's about 470 people in
the in the stream right now YouTube has
confirmed with us I have emails from
YouTube saying there is a bug on our
channel causing people to be unsubscribe
and we know that the feed is not going
out to people so for any of you that are
in here right now for some reason you're
on there but make sure that you click
that little bell so that you get all of
our notifications but also you can share
this it's becoming more and more
important they're telling me it's above
I don't like going down the conspiracy
routes thinking that they're doing
something for political reasons or
whatever even though I do suspect that
twitter is starting to shadow band a lot
of people with similar political beliefs
to me and we know that YouTube's de
monetizing a lot of videos on the types
of things that I talk about but that's
why it's important for you guys to share
these things you forget about patreon
for a second or PayPal that it's just
important for you to share it because
sometimes we're swimming up tide for
several reasons here we know that this
live feed did not have 300,000
subscribers this thing did not go out to
to all of you guys obviously so if you
can just share this if you want to take
a sec
maybe just tweet out a link or something
that would be great okay what do we got
your incessant kind of finish year since
the polls are cemented and voter turnout
is going to be accelerated
yeah I think that is actually a
possibility his question was ever do you
think there's a chance we'll have like a
braixen style election here pregnant
meaning that everyone thought they were
gonna stay the polls all imply that and
then they did decide to leave the the EU
I think that is possible but you have to
keep in mind right now that the forget
we like the Trump base is still excited
they are there they're angry and they're
excited and they're pissed and they're
engaged the Hillary base and the Machine
it's like it's working clearly the
player to believe the halls which I have
no reason not to believe then she's
winning without question but there is
more excitement you may not like what
that excitement or there's more
excitement on the Trump side so I do
think it's possible that's what and I
also that's why I said I wish that we
had one more debate just like three or
four days before the election not 20
days out because so much can happen in
the next 20 days so I think I really do
think that anything is possible at this
point I don't think it's a foregone
conclusion and I think that it will be
just natural just because of the way the
media is that they're going to want this
thing to tighten up before before it's a
couple quick shadows ginger erupted on
patreon thank you and brain and just
jumped in on patreon so thank you you
guys are helping build our studio Emira
uh who are the four horsemen at the the
four horsemen of the all right and the
all left so I guess that depends on what
your definition of those things are if
you're assuming that I'm part of the all
left meaning that there's this new group
of people that are not regressive left
people so then there's obviously I'd
like to include myself in there but I'm
in the online world sir I would I would
include Sam Harris in that obviously I
would include somebody like sargon of
akkad I would certainly include much of
your laws
I would include ayaan Hirsi Ali you know
fewer the people like that in terms of
the all right
again it's you know these things it
successfully this is tough with labels
and we're trying to you know you have to
sometimes use labels so people have a
broader sense of what you're talking
about but I try not to get too hung up
on labels but in terms of the alright I
would say the leaders the failures in my
world that all my crew would probably be
Milo and Serna [ __ ] and Scott Adams
and maybe like a lauren southerners like
I don't know they all count themselves
as all rightists alright people really I
think there are Trump supporters first
well I can't I can't speak to her Lauren
southern exactly but maybe a guy like
Paul Joseph Watson or something but it
isn't any of these people that I've
mentioned I some of them on the show and
I would be happy to talk to all of them
again yeah so there you go so this is
combining a question from Steve says
have liberals got out of control and
then someone else says I'm exaggerating
these things like abortion pride oh he's
pro-choice but how does the far-right
view us now yeah so basically a couple
people asked on patreon the same sort of
question of like how the liberals just
gone so crazy you know to the point
where you could say that you're you're
for abortion now you eat that that [ __ ]
walks like all of this stuff yeah
they've gone crazy and that and that's
why I've said repeatedly it's the left
won't deal with issues honestly if the
left will talk about immigration
honestly but instead the second you say
something about borders if you get
yelled at as a racist or a bigot well
then what's gonna happen it's going to
strengthen the right it's gonna
strengthen somebody they'll come in with
an easy answer it's easy answer to just
say I'm gonna build the law I don't
think Trump is gonna build along I don't
know that it's financially sensible I
don't know why Mexico would pay for it I
understand why he would try to trade
trade change trade deals to make it
happen but this is why the left has a
lot of what's happened with the rise of
Trump is a direct causation of the
language control on the political
correctness and the use of these phrases
of Islamophobe and racist and bigoted
and all of that which is why I've tried
so hard to clean up the left and I think
I've done a decent enough job of it and
there's plenty of other people that are
doing the same thing but we need to we
need to be better
because we're completely being pushed
out of the mainstream I mean I said I'll
see articles written about we were
they'll call me
micro 2-piece mi c-calm wrote a piece
and they call me a right winger and then
of course I and they wanted me to be in
the original piece by the way and I
sensed that the writer was just a
[ __ ] artist so I said no I'm gonna
pass no thanks
then he in the article he writes that
I'm a right winger and then when I
publicly shamed him which got hundreds
if not thousands of favorites and
retweets of course he didn't respond and
their editor-in-chief didn't respond
that I know someone that works there and
I contacted them and said there's
nothing I can do and it's like you guys
are all clickbait losers and you've
tribute try to that's why the the cries
of racism and bigotry are so dangerous
the left has used them so overboard that
they become meaningless and you're
getting a counter-reaction of people who
now want to use Nazi memes to to
basically upset people and yeah it's
just it's just a big mess what are we
doing here we're raising funds for our
new home studio we got to insulate this
thing we got to build a lighting grid we
got drywall all kinds of stuff that we
got to build out a meeting with the
contractors over the next couple days
it's very exciting where to start
doubling shows doing a lot more content
remove art calm / donate we have 700
yesterday we opened up 11 slots at $100
level to join us on the mini group
hangouts Google Hangouts video where I
talk to people all over the world with
little groups of 10 or less we have
seven slots left on there you can join
us for patreon chat mugs t-shirts and
all that good stuff
and we're doing a patreon only no matter
how much you donate just for tonight
whether it's a dollar or a hundred or
whatever patron only chat on YouTube
right after this do employers have the
right to fire workers for what they say
on the internet you know I used to give
a lot of the anonymous people [ __ ] and
then a lot of people would write back to
me Zach lose my job if I said what I
thought I'm not talking about people
that are closed society so I'm not
saying that if you're you know a Muslim
majority country or you know hearing
you're in Egypt or something but if
you're in the West to the employers have
a right to fire you for something
set on the intra basically I would say
though an employer you work you enter a
contract with an employer to do your job
and if you are doing your job you should
not be allowed to be fired for private
thoughts now if you publicly let's say
on your Facebook page it says that you
work for Microsoft and you're fighting
with people online all the time but
you're saying really racist [ __ ] or
open-top [ __ ] and it implies that you
are a representative of Microsoft that's
a slippery slope but generally this idea
that we could be fired for our thoughts
or or for political wrong thing really
is what it's about because you wouldn't
be knew there was a there would be a
slew of political thought you'd be
allowed to say a thing the popular
things no problem so it would be a
little wrong thing things you guys know
that I say things that are considered
wrong thing these days so I would be
very against generally company firing
people for personal beliefs all right a
couple quick thank-yous John on patreon
Benjamin who donated $4.20 for 20 a lot
of for 2011
we know Benjamin's doing right now
suresh who donated on PayPal and
Alastair jumped up on patreon thank you
guys
Dave on patreon he said should I up my
patreon or keep my sunday NFL ticket my
wife says I cannot vote your NFL ratings
not too good this season so they do so
they kind of need you but at the same
time you know I'm trying to save the
world over here so it really that's what
it comes down to you know anything you
can watch you can probably find a lot of
those streams for free but I know that
you would not hijack our stream and find
it for free so I've never given anyone
systemic concussions that's very true
and you know that's the choice David's
got something Java paid trying to speed
your mind to get you killed
for example Charlie Hebdo my speaking
your mind free speech more important
than preserving can save you I mean
that's that's deep all right so
basically he said if free speech could
get you killed like with the Charlie
Hebdo guys why is that more important
than your safety because without free
speech and without free thought and
without free expression what is the
point of being alive I mean all of those
cartoonists did was share a politically
incorrect thought and if you know
anything about Charlie Hebdo they were
not actually mocking Muhammad per se
they were mocking the hypocrisy of
religion which by the way only 3% of
their covers dealt with Islam and they
they were an equal opportunity offender
where they made fun of Christianity and
Judaism and a bunch of other things all
the time
we need those abilities that the whole
purpose I think of being a human the one
thing that separates us from the animals
is that we have a thinking consciousness
where we can actually make judgment
calls make decisions expand on what the
human experiences and if you and the
idea that we would live that you would
live and not say something that you
believe are not expressed I mean that
you believe because it might offend
somebody who then might kill you well
you better [ __ ] say it because then
otherwise you just will live your life
as hostage
so I refuse to live my life as a hostage
I know that upsets some people but I
just simply won't live that way and by
the way if you get if you say to
somebody you know all right you can
decide what cartoons I brought you don't
me to draw that cartoon I won't draw
that cartoon
do you think ultimately they're gonna
stop there or there are they soon gonna
say you know we don't want you to have
your women wearing this or we don't want
Gabey bars in your area or we don't want
this or that it's not gonna stop with
that tolerance is a two-way street and
don't be tolerant of intolerance because
it that's just a slow death Seattle says
he's he wants to see the gay community
kind of wake up in the gay friend
Hillary boss but then someone else says
they live in Tacoma and a lot of people
supporters wow that's interesting so the
first part of the question was somebody
saying that the gay community should
wake up that they're all Villere box
and then somebody responded in Tacoma
and said that a lot of the gays there
are some people I think that's really
interesting because I live in West
Hollywood here which is it's basically
like the gays place on earth I don't
even think I'm gay enough for this place
we got rainbow crosswalks every every
restaurant and bar is gay you know gays
all over the place and sometimes I think
when I'm here you know if you if you go
here it's like every guy is jacked and
buffed they work out all day long and
it's like I wonder what it would take I
was in Trader Joe's once and there was a
guy in there who clearly he didn't look
like he was a West Hollywood guy and he
was I think he may have been on drugs or
something and he was kind of yelling at
people and sort of like you [ __ ] [ __ ] like
muttering under his breath and getting
in people's faces and all these guys
that worked out all day long that have
muscles on top of muscles nobody did a
thing
nobody did a thing they all kind of
walked away and skirt it away and
whatever now I didn't do anything either
okay so I'm including myself in this
group but I do think that what that Mylo
does make one point correctly what he
talks about this stuff that gays I think
have to learn how to defend ourselves
and you know when this guy shot up the
pulse nightclub in Orlando it was really
sad and pathetic to see what so many
people on the Left were doing which was
that their natural reaction was to
somehow defend Islam or suddenly make it
seem like Muslims were the victims of
this when one particular person did it
in the name of a bad idea gee but gay
people were thrown under the bus because
this is what the oppression Olympics
does gays are el below we for some
reason Islam is the highest it's the
least progressive thing out there I'm
not just saying that go to any place
that is governed by Islam it's extremely
unpress it and but that's at the highest
of their oppression Olympics and gays
are below that women are below that now
so they have to throw everybody else on
the bus under the bus for that so I do
think at some level gays have to start
defending themselves properly or at
least with at least having these
conversations and believe me I get into
it all the time with my gay friends
anytime I say something remotely
anti-hillary everyone gets their panties
in a lot you know but you gotta keep
saying what you think well there you go
no big deal I don't want any extra
credit or any points for it but I might
even act
yeah yeah are you ever gonna get Emma a
sibling either aren't you am I ever
gonna get Emma a sibling either canine
or Cuban well people say that people say
the David and I are we gonna have kids
and I say I don't know but we're gonna
keep trying and I don't think Emma's
gonna have a canine sibling she's been
such a great dog and as I told you guys
she's from New Orleans after Hurricane
Katrina and she's had a couple puppies
over the years and she's just wonderful
and she's had a good life and she's
lived in New York she's lived in New
Orleans she's lived in New York City she
now lives in LA she's been to the Grand
Canyon she's been to the White House
she's been to the Washington Monument I
mean she's really been around I don't
think I would want to upset her with but
she doesn't then we got about 12 fish
over there that she is she does get to
see all right someone just said one of
the one of the hungrier slots on patreon
that was Shane who just upped on patreon
from 15 to 100 so I look forward to
Chuck
chatting with you in the group Google
Google in the Google hangout we got six
slots left and these are just mini video
chats that I do with people all over the
world it's really it's fun and it's cool
and I've got to know you guys and you
guys have not gotten to know you guys
would keep keep talking without me that
would be fine too hmm can you be over in
for sometimes I think I'm over in for
well more than over informed I think
sometimes that I wish that I was able to
put some of this stuff aside sometimes
it's become so big and especially in an
election year like this that it is hard
to shut off sometimes you know I can lay
in bed and wake up and immediately
scroll Twitter and be slammed with so
much information of people saying nice
things to me or horrible things or
whatever and you know there's just
endless news cycle so I think I don't
know that you can be over informed in
terms of your breadth of knowledge but I
think you could be over stimulated to
the point of stupidity and I think
that's one of the things where everybody
pretends that they're experts in
everything and I never try to do that I
like learning from people the best
example that I can give which I've said
a couple
is when we had that thaw in relations
with Cuba I guess that's probably out a
year ago now suddenly all of these
pundits and comics and people actors and
everyone on Twitter was going on and on
about Cuba I never heard you say
anything about Cuba ever none of you I
never expressed any opinion on Cuba and
you're all experts in relations and the
thawing of them and Castro and Bubba and
it's like stop pretending you don't know
what is everyone if it needs pretending
no every time I want to thank a new
shame we have back to back Shane Shane
just jumped on patreon so welcome Lord
Cheney's a particular level which is
gonna get him a Reuben report coffee mug
also works with whiskey by the way and
you get a t-shirt and you get every you
get every reward before that by the way
Ruben report on slash donate what are we
doing one more day of these live streets
this is our big push for the week we're
gonna build out studio and do all that
stuff then we're gonna do a lot more
live stirred stuff but it's gonna have
nothing to do with fundraising you know
we did this back in June when we built
our studio I don't intend on doing these
twice a year well maybe do it once a
year after this and not even necessarily
that but we've got a nice little company
going and an engine growing and it's
because of you guys I mean I wish this
[ __ ] thing was going out to the feet
because it's unfortunate that there's
only about 600 of you guys in here right
now because I know it's not going out to
the feet I mean YouTube is basically
told us that and told us that people are
being unsubscribe I don't know what I'm
supposed to think about that and they're
there the game in town you know for us
to for us to be heard so it's kind of
shitty but if you can keep sharing these
videos that that's the most important
thing that you do what's your what's my
definition of presidential is it based
on a behavior or an outcome or both I
would say I would say basically both I
think that you know look we're not
voting in a key we're not voting in
someone that is gonna rule over us
they're supposed to answer to us they're
supposed to sign things into laws so I
think it would be it would be great if
we understood that the power of the
presidency is only a third of the
government and he's not supposed to make
laws he's supposed to sign laws so I
would say that the the president should
more than
anything else have a and this maybe
Trump's biggest flaw I would say and by
the way Hilary's not great on its either
but I would say you have to have a
vision for what you want the country to
be and that hopefully you could Knight
people because we're all looking for
some sort of leader to basically have a
vision for what this country could be
like and they'll let the process be part
of the process enough to help some laws
some laws get passed or help change some
things or whatever but I don't think the
president has to be I don't think it's
purely based on outcome and I don't
think it's purely based on ideology I
think it has to be someone that
basically wants to do good for the
country and as a decent moral Center my
eight my main issue with Trump is that I
don't know exactly what his moral center
is and my main issue with Hillary is
that I think she's made a lot of
terrible decisions but here we are with
these two who's my favorite world leader
yeah it's a trap that's well done
hold on I'll do it Gary what country is
this where am i where are my shoes who's
my favorite world leader I would say
that the best world leader at the moment
well I hit her I'll answer it this way I
think probably the greatest world leader
ever was Winston Churchill who at least
in modern times right let's say in the
last 100 years because what Winston
Churchill did was realize what was
happening with Nazism and laid down the
law to not allow it to spread and then
the United States became part of at the
Allies eventually we won world war two
you need leaders that have a certain set
of principles and Anna a Goethe just put
Winston Churchill quotes in Google right
now just press images and you can see
some amazing quotes from this guy yeah
she did
live by a lot of this stuff it is not
easy being a world leader it really is
not you know and none of these people
are perfect and a lot of them are
extremely flawed and a lot of them have
good intentions so a simple way that
Gary Johnson could have answered that
question by the way if he couldn't he
just couldn't think of anything he
literally couldn't think of any
or leaders that's the problem maybe it's
the lead but he could have said somebody
like he could have said well you know I
don't know who's a great world leader
but because I you know I know that in
Germany they've had a really rough
history and they've tried to return for
their history an angle of Merkel has
tried to do good and giving them a
basically good economy and she's made
some some tough decisions with
immigration that haven't worked out the
way she wanted but she's you know help
them be part of the I mean he could have
come up with something that would have
had some semblance of decency but he
just dropped the ball that's very
disappointing to me shitlord on patreon
welcome board shitlord and Franz just
upped on patreon from 20 to 50 so it'll
be getting mug and a t-shirt all the
rewards before that and it's YouTube doc
it's youtube.com/scishow and a part
that's where you're at right now and
it's patreon.com slash room and record
room for consolation
donate and you guys are helping build at
our studio we did build so we built this
to you that we were renting so we've
rented space and built a set in our
studio but there were other productions
going on there and we had to pay every
time we did it and as I mentioned
earlier it started becoming financially
unfeasible for us to do more because the
more we were paying for the studio we
were actually losing the more content we
made we started losing money per episode
the more content we made because by the
way YouTube pays us out it basically
wasn't financially feasible all the time
sometimes we've got huge numbers and a
huge guest it would be worth it but if
we had a more random person in the
numbers were lower and I don't want to
do everything based on the most popular
people I want to bring you interesting
people it was becoming not financially
sensible and then we realized that
really the last the last piece for
freedom we control our we control our
company I control you know we have
employees and health insurance all that
stuff and then the last piece to true
freedom to decide who if we're going to
do distribution deals or how much
content we want to create or do we want
to do more than just an interview show
do we want to do a a weekly news thing
or other live search or any of that or
debates be a lot of people want me to
moderate debates which I'm totally down
to do we're really the only way to do
that properly would be to fully own and
control everything and that's why we
decided that the home studio was the way
to go so I took out two big loans but
I'm confident
we can we can do this well and and you
guys are helping us and by the way as
I've said before you know when you when
you donate glue the lighting on people a
lot of students I can't afford to donate
when you donate you help keep this show
3 so that we don't have to put it behind
a wall or anything and all that content
still remains on YouTube and iTunes all
that so you're helping these ideas so I
think hopefully it's you think it's an
investment in yourself as well thoughts
a vegan ISM I'm not a vegan I love meat
I'm a big meat-eater if you want to see
some of the things I'm eating by the way
go to Instagram comm slash David's
cookbook David's an incredible chef
I'm very spoiled that way in terms of
the type of stuff that I'm eating on
time I have no problem with vegans when
I lived in New York City at fairway I
lived on the Upper West they had like
their Rican area upstairs a lot of green
people
everyone always looked a little green to
me look like they could use a piece of
beets frankly but I know front plenty of
people that are vegans and they're good
people and you know I try to get them to
just when you just have a little piece
of chicken
but yeah I'm fine I'm totally fine with
vegans you do it you do what works for
you quick thanks to Malcolm who just
jumped up on patreon and to Dan who
joined on patreon welcome to boring
people live shout outs to anyone that
joins us on reboot for calm slash oh
it's gonna be over soon but we do have a
patreon only stream after that where
depending on how many people are awake
I'll leave a lot of people Europe
sleeping right now there could be there
could be a dozen people in there there
could be a hundred people in there it's
a lot easier for me to communicate
directly to you guys where we that's a
good one so as a gay man do I ever feel
disenfranchised by the gay community
because I've different views yes hugely
I think I've always sort of felt this I
had a show on Sirius XM which was on the
how cute channel which is the LGBT
channel I always want to do politics but
they just threw me on the gay Channel
because they were like you're gay you're
going on the gauge channel it wasn't
really where I wanted to be I wanted to
be on the nonpartisan political channel
which existed at the time of lecture
that still exists but anyway yeah I've
never been I've never really been
to groupthink so I've always sort of
thought as the outsider I'm gonna you
guys saw this I tweeted that bunch this
week but you know Peter Thiel who was
one of the founders of PayPal an early
investor in facebook the guys were you
know billions of dollars who runs tail
capital and spoke at the Republican
convention I don't know that he was even
a huge Trump supporter but he's he's a
conservative so to speak but openly gay
he got there was an article in The
Advocate this past week you can find it
it's a [ __ ] horrible article about
how he's not gay he's not really gay
yeah he has sex with dudes but he's not
really gay because he doesn't identify
with the gay struggle the
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh and it's like what
[ __ ] what what regressive [ __ ]
he's gay
cuz it takes one thing to be gay and I'm
pretty sure it does so he's gay and for
you to say he's not gay because he is
different the Advocate the Advocate
would you supposed to be an advocate for
gay people and gay exactly it's
completely irrelevant by the way I don't
know any gay person read but the point
is that what they tried to say is that
the mainstream gay groupthink now says
that if you think differently
politically you're not even gay I mean
it's actually disgusting so I went on a
very vociferous defense on on Twitter
and and I would love to see the gay you
know the gay community loves diversity
right we love diversity we love I don't
really care for drag queens but we
though you know they love you go to a
gay pride parade every single call her
person oh uh feather'd bla bla bla love
diversity diversity of thought not so
much I think the gay community do we
believe our side investors in the
company we don't have any straight-up
outside investors meeting anyone that
owns a piece of the company we've had a
couple of people that have given a
little bit more than say the average
person you know you can look on the on
the donate page you know you can give a
thousand to get this or 2,000 get that
or 5,000 do that we've had a couple
versions of that but we I 100% owned the
company and I think that's the best way
to do it we've had offers I've had
several offers for people to buy chunks
of the company and I was even even in
this process of having to take these
loans to do the home studio thing I've
been thinking about selling the sir
he said that I'm really trying not to do
that yet but I've had a couple offers
for that but I but that's why we really
want to hit this 30,000 thing because
then I know our finances are fully good
for you know the near term or even a
long term and we can build out
accordingly and hire some people and
start you embark on check alright we got
15 minutes left on this baby we're at
twenty five thousand five hundred ninety
five on on patreon we have six slots
left at a hundred dollars to join us on
our Google hangout monthly and you know
what can I do for the good people that
would excite them that would say I will
jump in probably say it's all about
taking a shot for you people I do have a
lot of patron over there maybe I'll do
it defending someone make an offer that
but I think there's a little bit left
but if someone wants to make me an offer
I can't refuse maybe I'll do a shot or
two but I'm trying not to drink on the
weekdays but for the purposes of this
all right maybe I'll do so make me an
offer I can't refuse I me right what do
I think opposed in the last decade I
mean look I've said this a couple of
times the last few days
I think it's obvious that there's
something going on with Russia right now
Mitt Romney was mocked by everyone
including me four years ago when he said
that Russia's our biggest political foe
and right now what's happening when we
see Russia's expanding and the u.s. is
taking a step back in the world in and
of itself that doesn't necessarily mean
anything is bad but Russia is has seems
to have completely reverse goals in
Syria that we have although it's unclear
to me what exactly our goals are you
know Russia took Crimea which was
against the NATO charter that if they
went into a NATO country the NATO
supposed to protect them and NATO didn't
so you know he had a red light at Syrian
didn't do anything I think Hooten sees
an America in retreat and thinks he can
just do whatever he wants now I don't
know what he wants does he want to form
greater Russia again or somehow bring
back the Soviet Union I'm not totally
sure but I think we got to tone down
some of the rhetoric the real issue with
Russia right now is that if they're
somehow in cahoots with WikiLeaks
and let's say Hillary gets in we don't
know what they have so let's say
Hillary's the president and they've held
back a lot of blackmailing [ __ ] and uh
she's the president we could we could
end up in some really awful you know
Cold War or hot work situation because
of information that there's several
dangers here that you know you don't
want to go down the conspiracy route but
you got to at least think of and be very
clear there are people in DC and think
tanks thinking of this stuff right now
how do we shake off the political apathy
I mean I think the most important thing
to shake off the political apathy is to
be engaged the reason we got here is
because you know the two parties just
offered us so little of nothing that
this is the best to people that they
gave us from people are engaged right
now if Scott Adams said on the show and
I said what do you think of this just
disaster he's like this is chaos but out
of this chaos is gonna come some
goodness I've really come around on that
idea I really do think that no matter
who wins look at Hillary wins the Trump
people are gonna be engaged they'll be
fighting the system and engage you may
not like the place stands for but
they'll be engaged if Trump wins that
he'll the establishment will suddenly be
on the outs and they're gonna have to
figure out how do we get popular again
so I hope that people if nothing else
was staged and more than anything else I
hope that what we really get out of this
is a a viable third party we get a group
of people that are basically liberals or
classic liberals and mainstream
conservatives and some libertarians and
all those people who go you know what
[ __ ] the fringes we're all here we don't
all have to believe the same thing about
to think exactly what you think about
abortion you don't have to think exactly
what I think about taxes but we do have
to realize that we're here in the same
country and we want to live under the
same rules and let's let's get there
together I think that could form after
this a lot of work all right what are we
doing
Rueben report Comstock joining you guys
are helping us build our home studio we
got to put in a lighting grid try long
soundproofing and air conditioning we
got a ton of work to do over the next
couple weeks but we're doubling our
episodes to two week next week just to
show you how hard we're working Oh in
perpetuity our episodes starting next
week for a while we're gonna do it as
long as we can if we hit that 30,000
goal then
but you're helping us build our studio
we're gonna do a live patreon check
right after this I like to do is donate
live stream right here on YouTube but
it'll be for patrons only but you only
have to donate dollar to get that or
whatever works for you and we got a
couple slots left at the doctor dollar
level that a few people have just taken
over and four hundred dollars you join
us on our monthly google hangouts and we
talk to small groups to people all over
the world
we quick thanks to Benjamin on PayPal
Jake on patreon and Jean on patreon
thank you guys
Gigi torchon all right let's do
rapid-fire questions just fire off
questions that I can answer quickly give
me like 20 questions in a row Amira is
going to line them up and I will be
prepared for rapid-fire answers as
quickly as I can
by the way emma is having dinner as we
speak while we're waiting on that
something like Obama giving the internet
way so this was a massively
underreported story but basically the
United States has controlled the
internet for better or worse since you
know for these last 20 years that the
Internet's been relevant to us a couple
months ago or a month ago at this point
I guess they gave the Internet up to the
United Nations which now means that
countries that don't respect human
rights the way we do that don't respect
free speech doing we do now have more to
say over the control of the internet so
China and Saudi Arabia and plenty of
other countries I view this as a problem
you know if it ain't broke don't fix it
yeah the US shouldn't have a monopoly
over everything well the internet has
been working pretty great it's caused
revolutions look what happened in Egypt
it is it has changed the world and it's
been working and it's been accessible
and free and I fear that we've now given
we don't know what the ramifications of
this are yet but it's but it's a big
problem
why if it's it's working it's working
let's not have this thing be centered
censored this is the great equalizer
watch my interview that I did on YouTube
week with Joey in Egypt where
talks about this is a 30 year old guy in
Egypt who's a free thinker in Egypt who
didn't mind going on a video even though
I said if you don't have to show your
face and he said that his awakening was
the night because he saw on the Internet
he saw the night that Sam Harris was on
Real Time with Bill Maher that was his
own political awakening how cool is that
I'm 8,000 miles away or whatever it is
here in California that maybe more than
that eight thousand miles and and I had
my awakening at basically the same time
that's how magical as he described it
the Internet is and we got to make sure
this thing stays free for everybody all
right we got some rap requires that we
ready all right what am i doing for
Thanksgiving I am gonna be hosting
Thanksgiving David's gonna be making a
turkey for a lot of people on his side
of the family possibly some some Reubens
okay Peyer cake ah it's gonna say more
of a cake guy but I've been enjoying
some Paislee I've been enjoying some
pies I like I like an apple pie like a
rhubarb pie why is your hair amazing why
is my hair amazing it's it's got a good
fluffed today some days it's a little
stiff on camera some days it's got nice
wait we're in a wait it's working
favorite Republican primary candidate
probably ran tall because he by far was
the most different and I at least had
some libertarian principles I think
there were a lot of problems with him
and he dropped the ball and he just
wasn't a particularly good candidate but
I think in terms of a guy that I could
sit down and have an interesting
political conversation I think would be
Rand Paul they may read strange favorite
weed strain I like I've got the
granddaddy purple right now which is I
like indica heavy I don't need City but
I think anymore if I'm smoking pot it's
to not think so I like the body high not
the mental high so granddaddy purple did
you just ask me that it don't LaPierre
wavy okay I think you've been smoking
that 'some possible mac and cheese or
mashed potatoes I love both that's so
hard I mean mac and cheese a good mac
and cheese ain't nothing like a mac and
cheese
instagram.com / david's cookbook if you
want to see some of things how does it
feel when people are surprised to hear
you're gay you know how does it feel
that when people hear I'm gay or said
they're surprised you know I don't want
any awards for Who I am it's it's just a
small piece of who I am and I never
wanted extra credit or any pity or
anything like that
I wanted equal rights which now we have
equal rights and I want to be treated on
my individual thoughts just like anybody
else so you know not every gay guy is
what you're seeing on television there
are actual gay people out there that you
may not know reggae and they are good
thanks to Alexander on patreon keeping
the other night I'm not a great sleeper
in general I wish I was a better sleeper
sometimes I do find it's hard to just
shut this stuff off you know I've been
trying to shut down online a little bit
earlier because you know it just kind of
gets in your head and just rattles
around in there you can be looking at
your phone with instead of having a
private daughter into the moment
whatever I think about the broad stuff I
think about really I don't think about
like you know like the day-to-day my new
show really if my life doesn't really
worry me
I do think about drawing trends about
world war and AI all kinds of other
stuff that I probably shouldn't be like
brain cells on I'm left-handed all the
brilliant creative people are lefties
Trumper bill who's more of a creep I
mean Trump obviously comes off as more
of a creep but we don't know the Trump
has done anything he says he's done some
stuff you know in his locker in
JavaScript puddings bill used his power
to do stuff that we know for a fact
who's creepier everything being equal I
think it's still Trump but you know
words and actions are not necessarily
the same thing we're gonna wrap up soon
but it is patreon.com/scishow you can
report a group report such donate if you
want to jump in there and and help
reduce the Reuben point so real quick
real quick - Tanner and the exclusive
live stream just for patrons only
and you all get to me Emira and David
we're gonna have them in there you guys
can ask them without beat maybe I'll
stop talking for a minute which would be
nice and Amir and David will jump on and
that's for all patron so whether you're
a dollar or a 250 level or 500 or
whatever it is and all right do I think
Sam Harris would debate Milo Sam
certainly not afraid of debate him
actually going to see Sam he's gonna be
in LA for two nights with Richard
Dawkins next week which is going to be
awesome
and I'm going to a little private thing
after which would be really really cool
I was trying to get Dawkins on the show
his schedule is just packed and I think
he's taking it a little easier these
days
but hopefully I can make that happen but
I don't you know Sam he has no fear it's
taking out a popular unpopular position
and I think he probably would under the
right circumstances a lot of questions
about leaders we're gonna put those
aside
what's a what smooth and share share
share gaga yeah I mean I'm a little
share but I would gladly take Tina
Turner instead of share this is fire but
assuming is elected if Hillary is
elected you think WikiLeaks has enough
for her to be a peach I mean that's sort
of what I was alluding to before we
don't know what they had which even if
you're a hundred percent for WikiLeaks
that does create a bit of a problem
because they're it's a chance that they
wait until she's already elected to
really unleash the stuff and then if at
that point she's the president and has
the power and I reckon out well that
could be a problem so you know you know
I don't like going on these conspiracy
theories you know I don't like going
down these conspiracy theory things you
have to be leery they have a political
agenda for sure they seem to have a lot
of stuff on her that is just the reality
of the situation is what is your call to
action for the rest of
before you go number one priority for
people under gun what is my call to
action number one priority for you guys
forgetting for getting money for a
second completely really the most
important thing you could do is say what
you can think don't be afraid to say
what you think in real life to sit down
at the dinner table with your spouse or
your wife or your friends or your
co-workers and tell them what we think
the cries of racism and bigotry have
silenced people to the point that
they're there it is causing a lot of the
support for Trump now you may like Trump
and that's totally fine with me you may
like all of that stuff but we have
enough honest conversation what I don't
want to make it Spectrometer what
wherever you fall politically don't be
afraid to say what you think that is the
most important thing you can do share
videos doesn't have to be my videos but
share videos of things that will get
people thinking tell your friends when
you thinking if you lose friends because
they tell you when you think about
politics then you'll find better friends
I've lost some friends I guess what I
found better ones in last year so that's
what I would say is the most important
thing that that anyone can do is share
what you think we have we have the great
luxury if you live in the West that
you're watching this we do have freedom
for now but it freedom is not free and
we won't always have it if we don't
defend it so so there you go all right
my last two thank yous go to Tanner who
donated on patreon Thank You tanner oh
we've got a couple more Adam who donated
uh patreon and Steven who donated a
brother on patreon and Jonathan who just
donated on patreon so thank you guys all
everybody who is a member on patreon
we're gonna post the link to the private
chat right now so you can still jump in
on that I thank you guys and we'll do
one more of these tomorrow night and
we're building out some really cool
stuff and we want you down all right Joe